[Music]
now to tonight's daily download it's a
new era for BTS as jyn begins his
mandatory military service making him
the first of the group to do so of
course as BTS bandmates gave him the
warmest send-off posting these photos on
Twitter on their goodbyes and jyn was
also given a warm welcome as fans and
media swarmed the army base he's now
stationed at for boot camp in South
Korea
but before enlisting today he shared
this selfie of his new military haircut
with the caption it looks cuter than I
expected
I've been making a record for like a
year
yeah yep Kate Hudson is hitting the
studio I've been writing music since I
was 19 and like I've never shared it and
so I I just thought that would be one of
my great regrets like I have no
expectations why not just I just want to
put a record out and so I'm doing it and
I'm really excited the album is expected
to drop sometime next year and if her
previous visit with Jimmy Fallon is any
indicator of what to expect it's going
to be epic
[Music]
if the captain is really being
objective he should be putting the best
interests of his crew first
Captain Leah saying goodbye to below
debt due to
health concerns my injury is getting
worse the left side of my body I don't
feel anything after struggling with
nerve issues all
out of season 10 early captain Lee has
been at the Helm of the franchise since
its beginning earning his place as band
babe and the nickname stud of the sea
[Music]